[Musik]
o
der jonas kommen 2000 im sturm gab
das ist im bezirk perg in oberösterreich
und imposant ja ich bin da an die band
19 jahre alt kommen aus strengberg
bezirk amstetten und ich später noch
immer so viel geben nachdem ihre arbeit
commerce das war im bezirks im
burgenland und spuren
ich hoffe und bin 18 jahre alt kommt aus
wien spielte peter lux 19 jahre als
comeback bezirk krems land
ich spiele eben den theresa bin 18 jahre
alt kam ausgangs läuft diese mit wind
und ich begleite ich bin matthias ich
bin 20 jahre alt kanzlers und
psychologen und schlagwerk interessant
genug seniorenkino vieles ist im bezirk
baden hat r umspielt huber
[Musik]
ich bin bei der militärmusik
niederösterreich weil musik gesang mehr
leidenschaft die kombi musikalisch
werden wie zum beispiel stofftieren und
dirigieren und das machten oft extrem
viel spaß ich bin bei der militärmusik
weil ich gerne musiziert und mein hobby
zum beruf machen kann
außerdem kann mir nur für studium
verbreiten ihr bei der stellung den
wunsch gehabt dass die militärmusik wie
hab dann am nächsten tag direkt
angriffen und auch mal einen termin
ausgemacht ist vorspiel in den
semesterferien
es war sein einige fremden mir vor als
korrupt und manchmal das ist ja super
johann ist immer super nutzen cafés ihr
hobby und das haben wir doch das probier
mal und ihr habt dann eben in die
semesterferien wo es einen speziellen
tag für frauen gibt wo das vorgestellt
worden ist
im vorspiel dann habe man nur mehr einen
termin für als personals ausmachen
müssen die haben wir dann zwar dazu
musste um noch was geschickt und dort
dann eben gefragt waren wo hier versetzt
werden und da wie gesagt mit der musik
minusbereich und mit dem wald geschenkt
[Musik]
[Applaus]
also ich war zwei instrumenten verspielt
offen und auf der posaune oder moll und
dur tonleiter angeschaut und formal
jeweils vortragsstücke und vorbereitet
er wird bei musikschullehrer
jahresprogramm song steht also ein stück
und schüler und hat man dann die
tonleiter nachschaut eben mal und
kroatisch aber das ist ein sehr genau
auf der homepage beschrieben was man
braucht und dann zum schluss eine platte
stück bekommen
[Musik]
ich bin zu mit der musik in die hessen
wollten kommen
dort wollen wir dann für viele stunden
ungefähr enthüllt man heute zwar
vortragsstücke verteilt die tonleitern
und dann auch plattdeutsche stück um
nach dem vorspiel vorbei war
formalitäten auskühlt
[Musik]
im vorspiel aber nein zu sagen ist damit
per telefon & gamble und diese später
ist einberufungsbefehl im briefkasten
liegen und wie gesagt hat
[Musik]
eigentlich haben recht für erwartungen
kommt man nur denkt das anstrengend wird
ich habe auf jeden fall respekt er
verkauft aber ich bin eigentlich sehr
unvoreingenommen herkam august meine
erwartungen an die grundausbildung waren
auf wiki sehr gespalten
das war richtig herr geschnitten werden
aber wie ist das dann ausgestellt und
wir andere dran war erzählt haben
es war echt nicht schlimm und sie haben
spaß gehabt und wir haben auch sehr viel
gelernt und möchte grundausbildung
fischen über [ __ ] stellt aber wie gesagt
ist an vier wochen und die vier wochen
vergingen recht schnell warum sie die an
einer offen und man lernt in sachen die
mars uns nie gelernt hat wie eben die
chancen was mir persönlich kontakt hat
was komplett anderes ist dass sie sonst
niemanden dem wahrscheinlich gemacht hat
und ja sport natürlich was jetzt
persönlich ackerschott erste hilfe kurse
und selbstverteidigung was soll das
eigentlich interessante sachen samen und
eben sonst nie vielleicht erklären
[Musik]
ja die war ein relativ cool
wir haben viele neue sachen kennen
klären die beispiele starb führen die
regierung habe musiktheorie gehörbildung
ist extrem viel weiter gegangen aber
auch um ein instrument haben sich
weiterentwickelt hat man natürlich auch
vorne das leben kennenlernt ist ja
gezeigt bei dem militär muss ich war
echt cool starb führen gelernt
musiktheorie gehörbildung gehabt und die
auch immer gleichzeitig auf toni einen
anderen unterricht weiter machen lassen
und das beste ist wir können sogar sport
im dienst machen
[Musik]
ich erwarte mir noch von der weiteren
zeit dass ich mich weiter verbessern
auf mein instrument und als wir noch
viele auftritte haben
und wer nur dass ich einfach eine schöne
zeit hier noch weiter verbringen ihr
wart man nur für coole konzerte
stabführer und dirigentenausbildung und
dass sie vielleicht meine eigenen stücke
mit einem professionellen
berufsorchester ausprobieren kann
also für die zukünftigen media musiker
sorgen vom vorspiel braucht sich echte
fürchten das sympathische leid
es macht wirklich gar um 20 uhr im
einsatz
dann gehts wickel mit viel engagement
und mit motivation an die sache heran
und nehmt eure erfahrungen des zusammen
mit nach hause zu den kabinen nutzte
zeitlich weiter zu entwickeln weil so
viel zeit zum üben nie wieder haben wir
jetzt nehme ich alles mit was sie dann
dort macht und zum schluss spitz vor
egal ob er glaubt dass gute und nicht
ihr werdet es nicht bereuen
[Musik]